[Music]
what up guys welcome back to
off the record where we talk about
whatever we want
and on this episode of ask an expert we
have
eric here who's an accountant and uh
both me and joe have been on a while joe
more so because he he has like the the
speed turned up a little bit more
on a wild crypto adventure you want to
tell them about it and then maybe you
could
see what you would have done a lot of my
friends who are um
pretty well off like they have a lot of
money
liquid and assets and all that they um
they're just like amazed at the way that
i run myself and you know just being an
entrepreneur or whatever like
there's different styles there's
different personalities right
like you could be your nickel and diming
bezels or you could be
like more of a rockstar entrepreneur
like branson or whatever but
where i fall under is more of a um
how do you say cowboy
poker man with cocaine sprinkled on top
yeah so like i always tell people like i
know the rules
obviously but i don't follow them and
why is it have you met people like me
obviously yes right gamblers we're not
investors
we're just hardcore uh i was telling him
during the break like yo
if there is a 10 chance i'm going all in
because of that 10 chance is worth it
for me right so for example like
in bitcoin right they're saying that
it'll go up to 100 grand maybe even 200
grand
um so to me when i see it same being 30
000 i'm like that's cheap right versus
now people be like oh i lost my chance
it went to 30 000
right if it's gonna go to 100 grand
then to me even 50 grand is still a good
price
and i see it that way so i approach
crypto this way when i first got in
thanks to uh steve who helped me become
even more of a degenerate
i introduced you to the rush anytime
there is opportunity
i can't wait to spend my money so in
life
i think i'm pretty conservative as far
as like aside from the ridiculous uh
spears and
random things i might buy for the ratio
of income that i'm bringing in
i probably spend like 10 liquid so like
i don't spend that much money
i live in a garage my rent is like a
thousand bucks a month
i don't freaking spend but
when it comes to my net worth or assets
or everything
all of my liquid or things are tied up
all of my money
i probably invested over a million into
just
so many different things and in my bank
account i don't like to have money in
there
and i don't know why i hate seeing it i
hate having money in my bank account i
just
can't wait to go oh you have a business
opportunity
come here tell me here boom boom right
and then so the story starts with in
in um several years ago right this guy
he's like telling me you need to get
into bitcoin and i'm like uh
at the end every december i do this
thing where i buy gold coins
so i'm like nah no thanks and i got like
20 gold coins it was the same price at
the time bitcoin was a thousand gold
coins were a thousand
you know and then a thousand an ounce or
a thousand an ounce right so now
and one for one bitcoin it was about a
thousand fifty or whatever
you know now bitcoins what 30 grand so
you were telling me the right thing
should have bought 20 of those guys but
this guy
but this it's hard to listen to a
stranger right
like especially if like you just don't
know it was a new friendship oh yeah
and then like then he he he makes it
with ether
and and then he what like put like 10
grand and made like 300 grand on it and
i'm like is this
real this is crazy and from those kind
of gains i was like
i'm in i'm all years tell me what to do
next he found some other altcoins
that had a lot of promise so i was like
cool
and you know the kind of guy i am is if
people tell me stuff like and if i lose
money i never blame them because it's
still my decision right
so i was like yo just tell me as much as
you know
i go in probably put about 200 grand
into this coin
i never told him how much to put in by
the way no that's for damn sure
but you know what i wanted to be a
friend and i knew how many coins he had
and because i was like let's be even
stevens buddy
i did that came up almost a million
but instead of me pulling out the
principal or anything
i kept going and i said to the moon baby
let's put in another 50 grams let's do
it again
250 grand let's get more let's keep
going i went
to the point where i was taking out
loans to do this
yeah margin bro on top of that i didn't
pull
a dime out i didn't put anything out
because i was like
to the moon we're going to keep going
this 1 million is going to turn to 10
million i don't care
uh the problem was i didn't know
anything about crypto or investing
i didn't know the basic rules of like
hey man you do two times be happy with
that because my standards are different
like if i'm
if i'm used to huge swings right like
one day i have a hundred grand and then
tomorrow
it's 500 you get desensitized
and then uh now all my stock buddies
were like i would have been happy with
like
not even half there was a couple days
where he was refreshing his phone and he
came up 250
000 in a day yeah and that's his
principle
so yeah that i could have just yeah i
could have just um pulled it out
but here's the thing man it's like um
you know
i even like i was in a crazy place where
i owed
taxes on that obviously because that's
cash
i didn't write it off you're buying
stocks with it you can't
you know that's not a write-off you're
going to get tax on it because the
government sees it as
hey this is hundreds of thousands of
dollars you just have in your bank
account right that's money you made that
year right
yeah so all of a sudden i get hit with a
tax bill of like 130 grand
all my money's in crypto i'm like still
not cashing out buddy
and you have loans i said [ __ ] this [ __ ]
yeah i got personal loans to pay off
that [ __ ]
and i started selling off things and was
this guy a legend or what
i just started another business that's
all i did and i made more money and i
was like all right boom
it just motivated me to make more
obviously it should have
scared me into doing something different
which i did i'm more conservative now
and my friend scolded me because i just
bought more crypto
uh but i'm also in restaurants i'm also
in so many other things right
so here's my thing is like i'm really
happy doing this
but i keep being told that it's wrong
and it's difficult for me to know what i
should do
yeah because it could be a problem but
i'm also very happy living in a garage
it's like i'm the i'm the happiest i've
ever been
like plus real quick he also paid off
his lungs he's like completely in the
clear now
so it's almost like the universe just
refuses to punish him for doing all this
yeah i'm
debt-free i have more toys now
i have more crypto now i don't know you
know and it to me it's it's
but all of my friends who have a lot of
money keep telling me you're reckless
this is crazy don't do it
so i don't know what what to listen to
like am i doing something wrong
and then i keep feeling like i should
change joe listen to me right now
all in a v e s so
let's say he's a a money patient or a
money doctor right he shows up
do you diagnose him as perfectly healthy
like what do you get because i want to
get offended i just feel like
there should be probably something i
should be doing or maybe i'm lucky and
i'm not feeling the consequences
i just don't know what i should do now
yeah so the the biggest challenge
and you had an amazing story thanks for
sharing that what a roller coaster of
emotions degenerate roller coaster
promotions
so there's a couple of like factors here
that kind of like play a role in it
number one is
as entrepreneurs our risk tolerance is
vastly different than a normal person
making a nine to five
because our thought process is oh i can
always remake the money in my business
right i could just work a little harder
to make that money so our risk tolerance
is different we tend to be a lot more
optimistic we tend to be a lot more
um tolerant to risk we tend to gamble a
bit more because we feel that we could
just scale our company a little bit more
and make up that game that's what i did
so
he listened to steve yeah so i listened
to joe
and i'm like since i know half of what
joe knows i'll invest half
so i invested a hundred and we're both
on this roller coaster together and i
was like wait you know what this is so
irresponsible
i should learn about this so i just
watched a documentary on netflix about
bitcoin i'm like
i'm informed i'm like i know a
blockchain
been on this roller coaster so when he
saw like almost a million
i saw almost 300 grand on my block folio
and then we're like are we going to pull
out our principle
nope and then we just kept going
like i ain't pulling if you ain't
pulling that's true so meanwhile i had
pulled out my principle
so i think i get a little bit of points
hey you got some extra bonus points so
that's
a big challenge right is entrepreneurs
our risk tolerance is
vastly different like and that's why i
say it takes a very special kind of
crazy person to be an entrepreneur
and so that's that's why you invest that
way yeah now the challenge too is when
you're looking at like
cryptocurrency because of all the swings
we tend to like that type of
risk and we tend to like that emotional
high it makes me giggle
[ __ ] love it when it went sideways
and there was nothing going on
i was like this is i'm done
dude you both were like [ __ ] done for
like
10 months like done and now
because everything's exploding again
these boys are like in my phone at like
1 30 in the morning like just bought
more just bought more
just bought more putting in this pillow
too
but now what i'm doing is like i'm i'm
listening to a bunch of
a bunch of people at the same time
except for just steve
did i call it or why i called pretty
good you did call it but you were so
married to the coin you would never let
us sell
damn right but you never asked us you
never i would have never done it
i know i would have never done it i
believed in the company i believed in
you guys
if you guys thought i would have sold if
you're so ride or die i love it today's
video
is brought to you by curology so for the
longest time
i resisted a skincare routine i remember
and the reason why is because i am a
lazy human being
i don't want to do the research to
figure out what is the best cream
for what skin what do i need for what
and then i realized
i do want a girlfriend one day so you
don't do the shampoo method and
let it wash down now i still do that but
i do use face cleanser thanks to
curology
because they they've actually been
sending me a personalized package yeah
for about a year now your face does look
cleaner
thank you this is not oil this is
beautiful
cleansing skin i want things to be
simple i want things to be personalized
i want someone else to do the thinking
for me yeah and the process was super
easy i went on their website
i was like these are my goals for my
skin yo i'm trying to stop myself from
aging because
yo this boomer is already boomed enough
okay let's just chill at this moment
yeah we gotta look like we fit in with
our age group right
i wanna be like that grandpa that has a
hat backwards like this and i'm like
yo i belong with the crowd but i can't
do that if my skin
is wrinkly like a raisin you know what i
mean so i said anti-aging anti-wrinkle
anti acne or whatever this is the
formula that i would like
and they customize that for me and they
also
put in a moisturizer so i don't get too
dried up
and they also gave me a cleanser and i
was like i got sensitive skin he goes
don't worry
we got the right thing for you this is
custom
for you okay and pretty much
since it's so easy they just drop this
off on my front door
all i got to do is now use it and
i feel much better i feel much smoother
i like looking at myself in the mirror
and going
man you're beautiful and it's thanks to
curology
yeah there's also a bunch of other
products that i feel like people could
benefit from
like acne body wash and also emergency
patches you know when you like
got to go on a date or you got prom or
you got that interview and you're like
oh [ __ ] i got this random thing that
popped up out of nowhere what the hell
what you gonna do
put it on there emergency so if you're
ready for healthier skin and a routine
that makes sense do what we did and gave
curology a try
go to curology.com off the record for a
free 30-day trial just pay for shipping
and handling you crazy
that's c-u-r-o-l-o-g-y dot com slash
off the record to unlock your free
30-day trial
go to curology.com for all the details
thanks curology i'm not lonely anymore
me neither oh so there's thought there's
another challenge there right when it
comes to things is
is when you invest and it's really hard
to
to not be but you can't be emotionally
tied to your investment so we learned
that now
we're good boys now about that yeah i
think there's a lot
going on i mean even though you know
like my friends that do tell me they're
entrepreneurs themselves but
on the spectrum i'd say they're more of
the risk adverse
calculated uh big gainers
but different right they're in different
businesses like i'm in entertainment
like
you know they're like in farming or
retail and more
i wouldn't say commodities or like but
there's it's a different kind of style
right i think
in entertainment you're really just
selling feelings
and and and it's different from you know
selling a product like water or whatever
i don't know
right yeah but i think it takes
different minds and i was wondering like
um if there was a way to do it the
consequences are hard for what we do
obviously like those are big numbers
and then um if i put it into perspective
i'm like i could have been
rent free for the rest of my life or i
could have bought like a hundred
of my favorite cars right now
but uh i yeah it's just numbers it's
kind of like at a casino where they're
just chips how do you justify it because
you got into crypto yourself yeah so the
way that
your entire savings into crypto if you
didn't you're such a [ __ ]
well i guess i'm a [ __ ] so half of my
half of my investments are in crypto
that's my speculative side
and the other half is in index funds
right and so
the challenge with that and the reason i
did that that's more the conservative
a little bit more conservative i mean
that's still really risky actually like
for
half and half i like it that's still
very it's still relatively aggressive
though the one methodology that always
sticks in my head is pigs get fat hogs
get slaughtered
so when you do see these big pops so
hogs are like the big ass pigs right and
pigs are like the little like pink
little squeaky pigs like uh
i don't know from charlotte's web or
something like that right so when you
think of it
as you see these roller coasters and
krypto is hard because it's so
easily get emotionally tied to it you
have your dopamine and serotonin
dropping every time
you open up your coinbase it's like a
drug
that's like social media so the big
challenge with that is to
to start setting like priced markers in
your head
where if it hits a certain amount the
moon the moon and we all think it's
going to go to the moon but start
have like thinking a little bit
realistically of like hey if it hits
this
i'm going to cash out my principal and
like stick with that foundation
right so it's kind of like more of just
understanding what your risk tolerance
is
understanding how you invest if you're
an emotional investor if you're
very risk adverse or if you're if you
don't give a [ __ ] about risk
understanding that and also knowing that
like wealth is a long-term
marathon it's not the short sprint so
it's really easy for us to catch the
roller coasters and get really excited
and they're really depressed and really
excited and they're really depressed
and understanding like how we think
should also dictate the way that you
invest
and where like your decision-making
process is it might also be a
personality type thing because i
remember
when i first started going to casinos
i'd be like okay cool
my limit's like 100 or 200 bucks yeah
and that's
no matter what if i lose it or whatever
i'm gonna go home and i end up going to
atm like six months
just one more time or like i'm like you
know i'm at this rave
you know i fried my brain cells enough
already i'm only gonna take like one
extra c
pill and you take it and then i don't
know four hours later man it's just kind
of weak
you take more and more and more so i
don't know if like
i i do set those sometimes you know but
then like sometimes after you when you
actually get there is it the discipline
to stick to what you set
is that that's gonna help dictate your
success
it's a combination of the discipline but
also having the right people around you
to go
doing got the right people man i'll tell
you if you ask me should i get i'm like
you know you should
if we were a country right now um we
would all outvote you and we're the
idiots
that's how scary this is okay so that
side tangent right
plato wrote in the republic the
challenge with a democracy
is the next level from a democracy is it
is tyranny
because what happens is as more people
become empowered and able to vote
you have more idiots that are able to
make a decision-making process
and it turns democracy into populism
populism leads to tyranny
so that's effectively what's happening
if you guys were the idiots right the
village idiots and i'm the like hype
thank the voice of reason i would be
voted out because
damn right shut up boring dude shut up
expert
shut up we want to gamble
so understanding like just human
construct and just the
normal human behavior is really
fascinating in terms of
risk in terms of how to be an
entrepreneur in terms of politics in
general and just how people make
decisions
like it's really fascinating because at
the end of the day we're humans we're
spiritual beings living a human
experience we all deal with the same
issues of tribalism
the same challenges identity the same
challenge of self-worth
the same challenges of imposter syndrome
all of us should deal with the same
exact things
and once you start understanding that
then you're like [ __ ] why am i making
this mistake oh it's because of my
challenge of worthiness oh it's my my
challenge of over
exuberance optimism right so i think at
the end of the day everything roots to
like human behavior
because i'll dictate how you invest
they'll dictate how you hire they'll
dictate
how you run your life in general yeah
i'm trying to figure that out too
because there's certain things that i
feel like um
i should be depressed about but instead
of depressed
like losing money or whatever right i
don't even see it as a loss
i see it as like relief sometimes and
this is
weird because i'm like i'll make it back
but it also
i remember having about like a quarter
mil in my bank account just cash
and i was at the saddest point in my
life and i was like i know
i'm too safe i have everything i want i
have all these like my cars whatever and
i'm like i hate my life like it's boring
and then when i started uh
investing into crypto and all kinds of
other things it felt like i felt alive
again
and i don't know if i manufacture chaos
or whatever but
that feeling of like i'm not sure if i'm
gonna be poor or not
it feels amazing
but i do have so many feelings of
security
and this is probably shitty to say but i
could work for any one of my friends and
help their company
out to the point where like i'll i'll
make
so much money for their company too that
i don't feel like i can ever be broke
so there's a little you trust yourself
you're resourceful yeah i feel like no
matter what and i can live very little
and like like i could i could live in a
car i could crash on someone's couch and
then
i can rebuild it and that's kind of
exciting if you think about it right
yeah i don't know is that's not exciting
to you i don't know oh bro
no i don't know man yeah i think it's
kind of cool because it's like we always
talk about it right like if you go home
what would you do i kind of wanted to
try that yeah you live like a homeless
person in a lot of ways
yeah that's true what's really
interesting
when i work with a lot of entrepreneurs
in the cfo space the accounting space
is the surface level is the money right
the surface level is understanding
the business and the finances but then
as i dive in
i start asking deeper questions why are
you making these decisions why are you
spending your money what you do
and often what you end up finding is a
lot of us we end up becoming
entrepreneurs because we're filling a
gap we're filling a need
i was always a black sheep i always
wanted to prove myself to my parents
my parents always want to be a doctor
dentist attorney and i'm 42 now like up
until like
39 my dad just called me all the time
say i wish you got your master's degree
and that just
that screwed me up wow so i was always
trying to prove
myself and that's i think what happens
with a lot of entrepreneurs outside of
solving a problem and like finding
opportunity
many of us try to prove ourselves and we
chase that sense of validation
and when we chase that sense of
validation it dictates to our optimism
it dictates the decisions that we make
and just like there's a couple of key
words that you brought joe that you're
chasing this feeling you're chasing this
emotion
this sense of like this high of the big
gains and the potential upside
but maybe deeper down there's something
that's rooted inside of your
in your heart and your soul that maybe
needs to be a dresser or
talked about that that may alleviate or
just change that thought process
yeah i love fun risky things like just
even
extreme sports and stuff so it all does
the same thing
i think it's dangerous when it comes to
money though because of the consequences
well i don't know injuries are pretty
bad too
but in my opinion like losing a lot is
dang more dangerous than like the way i
do experience extreme sports because i
don't do it hardcore
why doesn't your dad call you anymore
and say you should have got a degree
he's still alive right still alive
so i have a weird story like i was
raised in a cult from like 12 to
32 in a meditation cult yeah oh [ __ ]
and then on top that too my parents are
refugees from vietnam more so they were
ingrained in their head like education's
own way to get ahead so he had this
weird like dichotomy of like belief
structures and all that stuff
and the reason that my my dad started
switching over from that education
mindset to like hey you're doing well
is i had to keep reinforcing to him that
i'm doing well and i had to keep
reinforcing hey you know i live in
orange county i got
and i'm not like boasting or saying like
i'm this big [ __ ] or whatever
but like he started realizing that you
know i got a kid and i'm able to support
my own kid as a single parent
everything's going well like
maybe eric doesn't need that master's
degree but it's taken a long time for it
and i actually had to push back i didn't
i just set these boundaries with my dad
whereas before like i was this
validation seeker where i would just be
like yes dad yes dad
and i had to push back like no dad i
don't need it like i'm doing well i got
a great business
so it's just again it's this human
interaction this really interesting like
understanding of human interaction and
starting to have like a life where you
set boundaries for yourself
a life where you start understanding why
you make decisions that you do
and then just like staying firm for like
what you believe in
that starts really changing the dynamics
of your life i would love it if you're
like if we're like
what do you want your kid to do and
you're like i want to be a [ __ ]
doctor that'd be funny
plot twist and it's weird actually
because my son's 17 he's going to be
turning 18
and he's graduating from high school
this year and so i've been asking him
hey what do you want to do because i'm
getting
right now he does school online so i've
been asking hey what do you want to do
next like do you want to go to college
because whatever he wants to do i'll
support and he says i don't know dad i
kind of want to take a gap year and the
asian american dad inside of me
the refugee side of me is like it's like
no you got to go to school but the
entrepreneur side of me it's like
it's like the angel and the devil right
the entrepreneur side of me is like
okay i dig it like there's no rush
to to go to school and get the degree to
get a
job that everybody else has like go
explore yourself go do your thing
and then maybe you'll find what you want
to have right because like i think the
challenge is like
folks are pushed down this direction to
decide what they want to do in life at
18. like i didn't
i didn't even know what i wanted to do
when i was 30. like i'm 42 i don't even
know what i'll do right now right
so that's a lot of pressure it's a lot
of pressure right so
the asian american side of me is like go
to school the entrepreneur side of me is
like dude do whatever you want for a
year and explore and figure out what you
want to do
and see what happens my grandpa would
say if you have a gap year you're going
to fall into a gap and end up working at
the gap
it's like oh [ __ ] don't tell grandpa
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you